alors que paris acte la fin de
l'opération barkan les maliens premiers
concernés par la décision française sont
partagés sans surprise pour certains
maliens le départ des troupes françaises
est vécue comme une bonne chose ces
derniers mois le sentiment anti présence
française n'a fait que se confirmer dans
une partie de la population
le tube halo avant que la france
n'arrive tout allait bien puis celle qui
a provoqué la guerre ici alors c'est une
bonne décision propre pays
est là depuis sept ans sans résultats au
contraire il ya des morts tous les jours
c'est une bonne chose qu'elle se retire
à quelques mètres de là le son de cloche
peut être à l'opposé avec des bamakois
plutôt inquiet du retrait français et
avec la volonté d'être constructifs
espérant que le pays sera avancée au
total equani ça nous arrange bien que la
france partent mais il faut maintenant
que les leaders c'est là pour le pays
nous sommes alliés depuis des années on
ne peut pas se passer de la france comme
la france ne peut pas se passer nous
donc il ne faut pas qu'on essaie de les
rejeter comme des déchets et que la
france aussi ne joue pas avec nous
paris a promis de coordonner son retrait
avec la mission de l'onu au mali
mélamine usma dont le mandat n'est pas
de lutter contre le terrorisme voit ses
bases régulièrement ciblés par les
attaques jihadistes alors qu'elle est
l'opération de maintien de la paix la
plus meurtrière pour ses casques bleus
elle peut craindre désormais les
allemands